welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Netflix has just dropped the
final season of Jessica Jones and the
show has a lot to impact from it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the season as well as giving my
thoughts on whether it delivers a worthy
send-off or not this is full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't had a chance to
watch the show yet and I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for click in this video I hope you
enjoy it now sit back relax and let's
get into my full breakdown of Jessica
Jones season 3 from the off you get the
feeling that Jessica possesses a lot of
disdain towards heroism and season 3
deals with her coming to terms with the
responsibility that has been thrust upon
her phrases like Captain America would
never have done that
wring out from the off and it's clear
that this isn't your cookie cutter
Marvel character at all
whilst this has always been a standard
for the heroine there's an increased
amount of eye rolling going on from
Jessica this time round and from the
outset and throughout she seems like
she's truly decided to be as distant
from humanity as well humanly possible
there's a huge shadow left over the
season by Jessica's mother and she
though the titular character hates to
admit it inspired her in some ways to do
good in addition to this she has to deal
with the fact that morality and the law
often opposites and she realizes that
she has to cross the line in order to do
the right thing even though she'll be
crippled legally mirroring this hogarth
played by Korean moss finds herself
losing her mobility physically after the
ALS disease slowly begins to take over
her body
Malcolm 2 finds himself struggling with
the morality of the law and it's clear
that justice isn't always well just he
sees firsthand that the law can be
lenient towards people which definitely
calls the need for vigilantes now this
sets of Trish's Ark and it's arguably
the most interesting use of the
character in all three seasons Jessica
finds herself put in a position of power
where she is reluctantly looking out for
only hogarth but also Trish whose powers
are beginning to manifest as she
eventually becomes like her comic
counterpart Hellcat this isn't made any
easier by the rise of a new bill in a
New York named Salinger which Trish
becomes entangled with after he kills
her mother and the season becomes as
much about Jessica saving Trish as it
does Trish wishing to save the city
overall a season really drives home the
fact that if we are capable of doing the
right thing then we have a duty to do it
no matter what it costs us personally
there is a true sense of morality to the
entire piece and examines how a lot of
those perceived as heroes by the viewers
are not too distant from Salinger should
they decide to step over the line when
Salinger is hospitalized
Trish is given the opportunity to kill
him however Jessica wishes to have
justice rather than vengeance
so that Trish will not go down a dark
path that she probably won't come back
from this is a transformative moment
that shows that Jessica has truly become
a hero and though she can't save the
show from being canceled by Netflix she
can at least save her stepsister
Salinger challenges that deep down she
does want to be a heroine even though
she won't admit to others and no she
initially denies there it becomes clear
throughout the season that this is the
case Jones tricked Salinger into
confessing his crimes after luring him
into a false sense of security and it
seems that she is finally done enough to
clear Trish's name and end the saga once
and for all
however in a shocking twist at the end
of episode 12
Trish kills the killer and thus descends
into darkness it's at this point that
Jessica questions whether it's worth
even being a hero as everyone else gets
to look away while she is the one that's
required to deal with it we get an
awesome Luke Cage cameo but the main
talking part of the finale comes down to
Trish and Jones facing off we learn that
once the line is crossed there's no real
going back from it and Jessica worries
that Trish's murders will escalate and
become less merciful the longer she goes
on if she is the one to judge who lives
or dies then surely even those who
haven't committed major crimes will
eventually become victims if their fate
is based purely on morality in the end
we head into a showdown with Jessica
fully aware of what Trish escaped
they're aiming hogarth Trish actually
realizes that she's the only way to get
out of New York and off to a new life
however Jessica exposes her online and
tracks down her transport which
literally puts the final nail in the
coffin for the character she shows Trish
that if she continues on the path that
she is eventually she will come up
against a good guy and therefore beat
the villain standoff between the two is
very subtext driven and you get the
feeling that they both sort of just give
up each willing did not really step over
the line and destroy the other one
this leads Trish to yield and she and
Prison comes to the conclusion that in
the end she was the bad guy in breaking
the law
no matter how corrupted it may have
seemed Jessica on the other hand hasn't
really accepted that she is a hero
either and she decides to shirk off the
responsibility after parting ways with
Eric who represents the darker path she
finally closes the door her past self
deciding to flee the life of a hero she
says a final farewell to Trish who's
been escorted to the raft and heads out
to get as far away from it all as she
can however when buying the ticket which
is appropriately purple she hears the
everlasting voice of kilgrave in her
head and realizes that this is the wrong
decision
Jessica defiantly turns round and heads
back out into the world ready to embrace
the fact that she is a hero and that she
will do good her influences further
showcased by Eric who decides to start
working with the police and it's a
really upbeat note to finish on that's a
bittersweet moment to end the season on
and one that feels triumphant was also
disappointing at the same time purely
because I really wanted Jessica Jones to
go on longer but unfortunately due to
the cancellation by Netflix this is
potentially the last we will ever see of
her in this incarnation it's such a
shame because while season 3 is probably
the weakest of the run it's still really
enjoyable
there's no heavy-handed messages here
and it's easy to put yourself in the
shoes of Jessica and Trish and deciding
who you would side with whilst the
costumes are really lackluster with
pretty much a scarf over someone's face
being the height of it the tense drama
created by Salinger and the question of
what it really takes to be a hero really
drive this season immensely
in the end it's pretty sad to see the
show go along with the rest of the
Marvel Netflix universe but perhaps this
is the send-off we needed knowing our
heroes are off into the world doing
their own thing against the grain
overall I enjoyed Jessica Jones season
three and it gets a 7 out of 10
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
the season and if you took anything
different from it then make sure you
comment below and let me know if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of this weekend's other big release men
and black international which would be
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who are never missed in
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]